دخل بوليفارد بورد موسوعه تجانس منذ
افتتاح قبل حوالي شهر باكبر 5 اشياء ابهرت
فالكوره الضوئيه والشاشه العملاقه وبحيره
لاجون موسم رياض الذين وصلوا للموسوع
التابعه
[موسيقى]
بين مختلف دول العالم في اكبر بحيره
صناعيه في العالم هذا ما نقوم به في بحيره
لاغون التي دخلت موسوعه جينيس كاكبر بحيره
صناعيه في العالم بمساحه تزيد عن اثنا عشر
هتارا
[موسيقى]
من منا لا يتذكر احد ابطال الطفوله
غريندايزر جريندايزر يتواجد في البوليفارد
في اليابان تحديدا باكبر مجسم في العالم
وقد دخل موسوعه جينيس بطول
33.7 متر
موسم الرياض يواصل نجاحاته ودخول موسوعه
غينيس في المنطقه نفسها في البوليفارد ومن
خلال الكره الضوئيه والتي دخلت موسوعه
جينيسكا اكبر كره ضوئيه الايدي بحجم اكثر
من 114 قدم وعشر بوصات من الرياض شهد
متروك العربيه
[موسيقى]